[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and what do wander and
daredevil have in common they both wear
red and lack vision
it's an oldie but a goodie and as chosen
by you guys on twitter the first topic
we're going to be tackling this week
from comic con is daredevil born again
it's my most anticipated project from
phase 5 and i can't wait to see some
[ __ ] on screen like it's friday night
on channel 5. wait delete that delete
that
anyway throughout this video we're going
to be breaking down everything we know
about it so far the cast and new costume
that the character has if you enjoy the
video then please hit the thumbs up
button and also don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into
daredevil born again okay so during
marvel's hall h panel at san diego
comic-con they unveiled a lot of their
upcoming movies and shows for both phase
five and six daredevil born again was
dropped into the lineup and because of
this we know a rough release date for it
the show will be premiering on disney
plus in spring 2024 and it'll be a
mammoth kingpin of a season clocking in
at 18 episodes this will be three times
is that right six twelve yeah three
times longer than the usual disney plus
show the typical season on netflix for
the series was 13 episodes so this is
gonna be even longer than that now that
doesn't mean it'll actually be longer
though as netflix entries all clocked in
at an hour each and disney tend to do
varying lengths with their longer
seasons normally having shorter episodes
for example your hawkeyes you miss
marvels they were roughly about 50
minutes long whereas a lot of one
division was about 20 to 30 minutes so
run times can vary depending on a series
length and with this being 18 episodes i
can imagine that they might be shorter
ones that don't clock in at an hour
disney will be dropping the series
weekly and kevin spoilers is about to be
busy for the next year so kids you're
going off to boarding school see you
chump now as much as i hate doing a lot
of episodes at once with this being 18 i
kinda hope that disney change up their
format a bit and do something similar to
amazon prime video tend to drop the
first three episodes of a season and
then they follow this with weekly
releases i think that would work really
well in this instance and that would
give us a big binge from the off and
then get us hooked on the weekly
releases now both charlie cox and
vincent d'onofrio are returning to their
respective roles cox is due to appear in
she-hulk with inoffrio once more
returning is the kingpin and echo so
spoiler alert he survives that show too
now at the end of hawkeye he ended up
getting shot by ekko but if you're aware
of the comics you'll know that something
similar happened in them in those
kingpin ended up getting shot too buddy
went blind instead of dying i think
they'll bring him back in this way so
that you have him facing off against the
death echo and her show before going
against a blind daredevil in his it's
sort of like poetry they rhyme and
vincent enough rio reacted to the
announcement the other day by simply
stating when i was a boy so yeah
can you can you be more specific mate uh
sorry for asking i won't bother you
again anyway the title born again brings
a lot with it and for the next part of
the video i want to go over that in the
costume now if you've read the book by
frank miller then you'll know that
season three of daredevil actually took
a lot of elements from it so it's going
to be interesting to see if they revisit
that or make this its own thing we're
still unsure if it's all connected to
what's come before but i can imagine
that this will be somewhat of a soft
reboot with some returning characters
but they might reduce some plotlines we
also don't know if the daredevil verse
characters will be returning but knowing
disney they're probably getting the
punisher across turning him into a guy
that makes balloon animals at kids
parties and calling him the punisher
you're some of a [ __ ] now i know that
disney have a reputation but i really
hope that they take the mature route
with it get rid of the hawaiian hats and
at least make these as gritty as the
netflix series if they don't do that
it's gonna get a lot of negative
comparisons but with marvel zombies
being tvma i do have hope that they
realize they can at least start going
into adult territories deadpool 3 has
also been said to be rated all and for a
property like born again they're gonna
need to go in that direction now in the
comics we see that karen page is a drug
addict and in order to get a fix she
ends up revealing that matt murdock is
daredevil so yeah already off to a bad
start and this info gets passed to the
kingpin who systemically destroys matt
murdock's life he ruins his career and
also destroys his home matt doesn't
understand why everything has all of a
sudden come crashing down but he
realizes it's kingpin due to his
arrogance kingpin's hubris meant that he
had to leave a calling card so that matt
knew it was him all along and this sets
him off on a quest for revenge in the
comics matt ended up fighting a guy
called nuke and on top of this he also
took down the kingpin now this was a big
comic at the time because this was an
age where the villains in public never
found out a superhero secret identity i
know that the mcu has kind of scrapped
that in favor of just revealing
everyone's but when they're these kind
of heroes it means way more tony stark
is a billionaire so it doesn't matter if
people know he's iron man but for
characters like daredevil and spider-man
it renders them unable to have a normal
life now though i absolutely love the
book and think it's near perfect the
nuke storyline was always pretty bad to
me and i kinda hope that they swap the
character out with someone else if you
cast your mind back to the ending of
daredevil season 3 then you'll remember
that bullseye ended up surviving the
series and i think it would be great to
get poindexter back if kingpin is blind
it also gives us a lot of crap-pun
opportunities to have someone in the
show called bullseye and he's probably
also my second favorite daredevil
villain i just think there's something
so cool about someone who can turn
anything into a weapon and use it in a
way to kill people with pinpoint
accuracy and it would be a great test
for matt murdock once more now until
this i hope we see deborah and will
return as karen paige with eldon henson
also coming back as foggy the pair
really added a lot of heart to the
original series and with the two main
leads coming back it makes sense to
bring them across two this could also be
used as a way to pull across the
defenders and who knows we might even
get cameos from jessica jones luke cage
and yes even you iron fist now if you
cast your mind back to the release of
the matrix resurrections then you might
remember that jessica henwick revealed
she didn't want to star on chongqi
because she had hopes kalinwin could
return i'd love it if she got to come
back too as she's by far the best part
of that series and henwick has also made
a big name for herself now so everyone
could come back but we could also get
some upgrades too this includes costumes
and in the brand new she-hulk trailer we
ended with an appearance from daredevil
confirming that he's gonna be in the
show my guess is that it's just a cameo
role but that he will help to set up the
events of ekko before he gets his main
series now if you slow down the footage
of him jumping you can see that his
costume has yellow elements to it this
pulls directly from the comics and in
those he did have a yellow leotard at
points which was based on a boxing
outfit i always thought this would look
goofy in live action but that's some of
the [ __ ] kevin feige he's pulled it off
and looks great from the small flashes
we get they haven't gone too over the
top with it and it still retains a lot
of the elements from netflix but it also
has these things that make it more akin
to the comics which a right marvel for
doing anyway that's everything we know
so far our theories and also what you
need to know about the comic books so
you've got a bit more of an idea of what
to expect in the show born again is a
brilliant book and the creative team
have a lot resting on their shoulders
with this my big hopes are that they
don't need a rip for disney plus and
that they lean into the darker elements
of it the audience that grew up with the
mcu are getting older now too so having
this be as mature as the source material
would be great for this series at least
i think anyway that's your lot and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you comment below and
let me know we're running a competition
right now and giving away three copies
of doctor strange in a multiverse of
madness on the 15th of august and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the series we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now see if that's you then message
me on twitter heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of the full
event which will be linked on screen
right now we talk about all the upcoming
movies what you need to know about them
and also what our most anticipated one
is i know i know i've already said it's
daredevil but uh just pretend i didn't
and go over and watch that without the
way thanks for sticking through the
video i've been paul i'll see you next
time take care peace